では今から忍者が好きな人のための言葉をいくつか紹介したいと
子供の時は孤独だった諸岡の弟いうずっと
バカにされてて殺す2の理科大ドロールあまだ生きてたんだ最後の一口を音が取るんだ
この身体の中に創造性するとてつもない化け物が潜んでいるの僕の好物を味噌ラーメン
であのずらすを見ろとか
感じねと誓ったんですの砂砂がせなきゃいけ文
com there アクセル子供の時は本当に孤独で
づらかった最初から家族がいないお前は何が僕は家族を皆殺しにした夜を抜ける殺す
チャナンカレーだろ
影分身だったんだ元気玉を喰らうじゃなくてそう
封印を破れ
破れさスキコンそこらちゃんなると空腹や卵快速ラチャ乗る特価すすキッズあこれなる
と文キャラン買えば語るスティックなると札幌本だよ前にみんな死んだのよ
よみがえった
何ゴミ車輪が使いすぎてささぁさぁスティック
僕は pain だ神羅天征和師はまだ釣り攻撃しか期間って言ったはずだ俺の新しい
実をくらいバックストーリーもないお前なんか俺を倒せるとての思っての傘は何しろ今
からフラッシュバックが流れるのさ
何1個時は本当に来どこだっ
していた
うん
うんにも確かに忍者遅いの声
それでも先生を教えてくれたん
殿っていうものの大切さ
そしてのインチ努力てー
そのうちに大事なものができたんだ
そう
僕には友達ができたんだ
だから今を守るべきものがあるんん
そして僕は強くなっててきょうは絶対にお前を倒す
まさかお前には友達という人は頭があるとってなんなよわれだ
ふむいい
[音楽]